dans le sud ouest de londres des
bénévoles se mobilisent pour faire du
porte à porte et proposer des kits de
dépistage
je travaille à la maison depuis le 18
mars dernier
je ne sais très agréable d'être dans ma
communauté et d'aider là où nous le
pouvons et de savoir que les gens sont
vraiment chez eux pour participer à
cette étude et à la recherche
ils sont une centaine de volontaires à
faire le tour du quartier à pied pour
distribuer ces tests de dépistage à
faire soi même
une initiative bien accueillie par les
habitants
je suis assez calme parce que je reste à
la maison donc mr ne changera mais je
pense que c'est bien parce que plus nous
faisons de tests plus nous découvrons
deux personnes qui auraient dû rester à
la maison et prendre des précautions
pour ne pas aller ailleurs
dix mille kits de dépistage seront
distribués à woking d'ici à vendredi
soir les bénévoles doivent ensuite
récupérer les tests les autorités
sanitaires britanniques veulent
effectuer un recensement massif pour
savoir dans quelle mesure le variant sud
africain s'est répandue le ministère de
la santé et des affaires sociales nous a
demandé d ravis qu'ils variant
sud-africain donc plus nous testerons
les personnes dans la région nous
pensons qu'il ya un risque que nous
pourrons identifier celles qui en sont
atteintes
nous pourrons alors abordé les points
vraiment importants qu'il s'agisse de
bize allmand du conseil du gouvernement
sur la manière de traiter des cas une
centaine de cas du variant sud africains
ont été détectés au royaume-uni une
souche susceptibles d'être plus
contagieuse d'où l'inquiétude des
autorités britanniques
le gouvernement a interdit toutes les
liaisons aériennes directes en
provenance de l'afrique du sud
londres a également fermé ses frontières
à une trentaine de pays jugés à risque